okay I guess like let's get started so
um
I think last week
um I I spent some time reading the
feedback from the survey
um I've been going through all of them
so I guess I'm not going to discuss
every um points there like all the
points are well taken and thanks for all
the for helpful feedback
um um and for some of those I'm going to
improve I guess
um there are also some other
um conflictory requests uh you know
which you know still are very
understandable because different people
have different preferences that's
completely fun
um um but I guess I'm just saying that
it's not like all I can address all the
possible requests just because sometimes
there are some constraints
um um but of course I you know sometimes
I think even conflictory requests can be
addressed uh if you are creative you
know I will try to do that as well
um
um I guess one
um
I I guess there's one thing I want to
discuss a little bit which I think might
be useful for you is not trying to find
any excuses for the for the lecture but
I think some people mentioned that it's
a little bit hard to uh follow the
um take notes well later in the lecture
I can completely understand that I wrote
pretty fast which I'm going to slow down
a little bit at least to make the layout
and form a little bit cleaner to easier
to read
um but I think in my opinion you know
this of course I'm not saying that you
have to really follow my way to take
courses like I typically don't take a
lot of notes
um I think at least this course I
I try to design so that you don't have
to take all the notes yourself just
because we're gonna have scrap notes
later and some of the scrap notes are
already there
um and I when I listen to a theoretical
lecture I try to
think more uh so that I can remember
them in my in my head a little bit
um because I feel that at least for me
it's it takes too much energy for taking
all the notes like um
um you know I'm not sure whether this is
useful for everyone maybe I don't think
it can be useful for everyone but you
know maybe you can try it a little bit
just to see whether it's easier if you
take even less notes and and try to
remember a little more
um anyways I'm I'm gonna slow down a
little bit at least in terms of the
writing posture and also probably I'm
going to kind of like slow down a little
bit in terms of the overall Pace a
little bit as well
given all the uh some of the feedbacks
saying that uh some of the lectures are
a little bit too fast
um and also another thing is that I
think the homework questions you know
indeed some of the questions I think I
probably made the mistake that uh a few
sub questions are a little bit too
difficult they were bonus questions in
the past offerings and at this quarter I
I thought that we have um you have a
team of three people so maybe I can put
them as regular points but still they
are probably a little too difficult they
require some kind of tricks as you
probably noticed some commentaro tricks
um right so
um yeah but I guess you know I checked
the the last homework I think there's no
nothing like that like most of the
questions are
um I probably shouldn't require anything
super special tricks about
commentatorics
um and and I guess another thing is that
you know if you want to take some bonus
points I guess there are other ways for
example to subscribe notes you know
improve existing lectures the if you
don't care about a plus I think a bonus
point
you know the bonus points is always it's
as the same it's the same as the regular
points in some sense if you look at the
the grading policy at least it works
from your perspective worth the same as
the regular points so
um so from the the basically the grading
policies that we first decided to cut
off before the bonus response and then
the bonus points can only make you
um have better electric grade
um okay uh anyway so
um so yeah I guess you know there are
other very very important uh very nice
feedbacks and which I'm going to
incorporate as well in the in the
lecture
um I'm not going to discuss all of the
supports just to save some time so okay
so maybe let's get into the
um
get into the the technical part if
there's no other questions other
discussions
um so so I guess last last Wednesday I
was sick and uh and we skipped that we
we like we ask you to watch the video
online and roughly speaking what we did
in the video is that we talk about this
optimization
like uh
non-convex optimization
and
I think so the main point there was that
if you're if you have the so-called
property of low low local Minima
or local Minima global
then you can find global minimum of
course there are technical things like
there is so-called strict cycle point
which we discussed in the video
um and and there are other kind of like
things
um that are a little bit subtle but but
this is the main part and and so
basically you only have to show that
this is true and then you can find a
global minimum of the non-conflex stocks
and this allow for a search from a
broader kind of kind of point of view
um is successful and in some sense the
what I'm going to discuss next is
another example of this
uh however
um there are some kind of like special
uh subtleties so so basically what what
we saw last time is that this is really
true globally the statement all local
minimum or Global are basically this is
a true statement for every for the
entire space
and today what we're going to discuss is
that you're only looking at a special
part of the space so in some sense the
function we are going to discuss this
today is like look like something like
this you have some kind of like complex
part about this function which you don't
know how to
how to characterize but you identify a
small part where this is true
you look at a special region where all
local minimum are Global and there is
actually a good Global minimum there so
then you just only work in that widget
um and
um that's kind of the the connection to
the previous lecture uh there are other
issues with this kind of approach I
guess we discussed a little bit in one
of the the outlining lecture
um the the limitation would be that you
know you identify this region where
everything is nice the landscape is so
nice but is this the reason you really
care about right so if you really care
about funding a global minimum of the
tuning loss then yes this has to be the
reason because you find the global
minimum of the chaining loss but if you
care about other properties right so
like generalization performance then
um um it might be not the right region
that you should focus on so but for
today's lecture we don't care about that
where we just say let's just we were
going to go through what this works and
then we talk about limitations and and
in the future lectures we're going to
talk about ways to in some sense improve
upon this
I'll kind of like fix the issues of this
kind of approach
um
okay so that's a that's a very rough um
that's a
um kind of like a high level overview
and also by the way if you haven't seen
my uh notes or announcement on ad so
there are actually two videos that we
asked to watch uh for making up the last
lecture so uh one of them is a full
action the other one has like 50 minutes
um so they are about this uh non-convex
conversation although coming my Global
Minima kind of phenomenal
um and this does relates to one of the
homework questions the question itself
is still in some sense self content but
but I think it's useful for you to know
the the basic idea
um even the basic proof ideas in those
two two videos
um so that you kind of see better how do
you do the homework question
um
okay so okay so today let's talk about
this uh this this
um this thing we are like about this
special region thing so and this is all
for
um called neural tangent kernel approach
I guess the the name doesn't really
you know so far just think of this as a
placeholder like I'm gonna I'm gonna
explain why this is called neurotangent
kernel
so so the the basic idea is that you
look at some special place
um around a neighborhood of your
initialization and you do some Taylor
expansion so so Taylor expanding
and this works for any non-linear
functions so suppose you have a
you have a non-linear
or even linear but non-linear would be
the most interesting case a nonlinear
Model F Theta X
and then you'll do a Taylor expansion
around
initialization
zero
so and when you tell expand the model at
the initialization so your model
is after the X you tell expand with
respect to the parameters but not input
so so the input is fixed and the
parameter is the variable so Theta 0 is
the reference point and then you look at
the gradient with Vector Theta evaluated
zero
this is the first other gradient times
Theta zero so this is the first order
uh um Taylor expansion and then you you
say you have some higher order terms
which we are going to ignore so and once
you do this you can Define maybe this
one
this let's call this G Theta X
of course it also depends on sale at
zero but let's say Theta is the variable
so that zero is fixed so this is a
function of theta
um so this is a linear function so
so if you define this then G Theta X
is a linear function in Theta
because where say that shows up say it
only shows up here and it shows up
linearly
and basically you linearize on your
um your your model
um and you can also I guess Define
Delta Theta which is the difference
between Theta and Theta zero
um I guess technically you should call
this not nearly this is a fine function
because there is a constant term right
function
um in Theta or in Delta Theta you know
they are not too different
um I guess just want to introduce this
notation Delta Theta
um
and
and
so I have to say that zero this
reference point
this is a constant
from this perspective right it's a
constant that doesn't depend the
constant for fixed X
but it didn't change as you change Theta
and and in some sense this is just a
um not that important and so so so
sometimes for convenience
so not very important
because it's a constant
and sometimes for convenience
convenience
you choose
to
choose
to the zero such that
F said that's zero
X is equals to zero for every X
um how do you do it so you do it so if
you really want to do this you know you
need to for example what you can do is
you can Design Network that
um you split your invite Fork into two
two parts right so maybe you have
suppose before you have a network we
have all of these connections
right so and then for the second layer
maybe for some layers split in two two
halves right so you have something like
this
and then something like this
and and you do the same thing in these
two halves exactly the same thing it is
two halves and then you put plus one
here and minus one here
so so that they got canceled so that you
have still a sum a random visualization
but by the initialization has a
functionality that
um you know the functionality of this
initial model is is zero I'm not sure
whether my drawing makes any sense this
this like you know
I see some confusion in your face but
this is supposed to be something simple
for example let's say
um
for example let's say you have some of
linear models some of sorry two layers
sum of AI times
Sigma of wi transpose X I from one to I
suppose this is a mode and what you can
do is you can say you add it to
minus AI Sigma w x y transpose X
so you have two amp neurons and and and
the the wi is the same and the AIS are
paired
right so then this it becomes
zero right so so if you have two ab
neurons and one part is the same as the
other part in terms of w and in terms of
a there are negation of each other then
you make this zero and you still have
relatively good Randomness right you can
still choose wi to be random as long as
w i these are all wides and these are
ARS so anyway this is a not super
important Point
um and also even you don't do this you
can still somewhat kind of get away from
it because this F Theta 0x is a constant
okay so so basically from now on we're
going to assume this f70x is zero in
most of the cases
so and and if you think about this right
so
so basically this is saying that
um so y Prime supposed to take y Prime
to be y minus this constant
which we are going to assume is zero but
so far if I say this is uh for this
equation I think we can still think of
as generic so then you get this is this
is a linear function instead of
transpose right so it's going to be
great Theta fc.0 x times Delta Theta
and this becomes a linear function in
Delta Theta so this you can think of
this as the parameter
and this you can think of this as a
feature map
so this is the same as the feature map V
of x
that we discussed for example in cx299
right when you have a kernel method so
and while this is a feature map this is
a pre this is something that doesn't
depend on the parameter right so Theta 0
is fixed already so F Theta zero of X is
really just a
fixed function of x
right so
um so this is a fixed
let's call this
of
given the architecture
and say that zero
but it's not it doesn't depend on the
outer fade
so in some sense not it just becomes
kernel method and and and this curve so
you can Define
um
oops what's going on so I guess if it
was
if for Simplicity
if you assume I have Theta 0 x is zero
then Y and Y Prime the same so basically
our fading a linear function onto our
Target and and this becomes kernel
method you can Define the kernel
okay
uh
x x Prime to be the inner product of
features
by the the
fee of X transpose V of X Prime which is
the inner Paradox of these two gradients
right so and and why this is called
neural tangent kernel the reason is that
this
is the tangent
of uh of the right work is the gradient
of the large work
I think then that's why it's called
neural tangential kernel because it's
the
the feature is the gradient of the new
network anyway the neural tangent kernel
is just the name
so
Okay so
and suppose
so suppose
we just use model we just use
G Theta X
instead instead of the original model
then basically you just get kernel
method
or linear
model
on top of the feature
right so and
and the loss function so suppose you
believe that
Theta is close to zero so when
then you can also kind of intuitively
say okay
my original loss function which is a
function of the model output and why
probably is approximately close to
my new loss function right which is G
Theta of x
and Y
and and this is linear
and the whole thing is convex
because L is convex right a convex
function composed with linear function
is still convex
right so when this but this is when
Theta is very close to
the zero
and so basically the question so the so
the remaining thing is just really that
so how valid
is this approximation
right because everything sounds nice you
know after we did this you know like
everything becomes super easy
um but in what cases this can be valid
um go ahead
[Music]
yeah so the inner Paradise just the the
typical inner product you just take the
because these two are just vectors right
so so okay so what's the dimensionality
here so
gradient of say this thing is in a
dimension that's a p if Theta is in RP
so it has the same dimensionality as
okay I guess it also depends on what f
is so let's suppose f is from
um some Rd to R right d is the dimension
of x
is the dimension of x
then but the problem the point is that
the output is one dimensional and then
you take the gradient with Vector you
get a p dimensional Vector where p is
the dimension of the Theta so the
gradient so the gradient with respect to
Theta has the same Dimension as Theta
that makes sense right so so this is a p
dimensional vector and you just take
inner product of two vectors
to define a feature
makes sense
cool okay so
okay so I guess to proceed and I Define
two notations just for the simplicity
so let's define IO hat of theta to be
the empirical loss with the model f
Theta
this is just for formality so that we
can write this easier in the and F have
G Theta
is the
laws
with model X G Theta
okay so the key idea is that
so in certain cases this Taylor
expansion makes sense right so
so I guess the the Taylor expansion
can make sense can can work
for certain cases
um here we're gonna hide you know
they're gonna what for what cases it
makes sense you know can work it's gonna
be a uh it's gonna be a big question you
know that we probably will discuss at
the very end but so far let's say just
let's see how the how does it work so
the way that they work is the following
so in the following sense
so how do you say it works right so so
you say that there exists a neighborhood
of Sega 0
such that
in this neighborhood so let's call this
neighborhood B Theta
zero
such that
the several things happens so one thing
is that you have an accurate
approximation in terms of function value
so the F Theta is somewhat close to G
Theta f x
and and I had as a result I had F Theta
is close to L height G Theta
for every Theta in this neighborhood B
Theta zero
so that's something you want
which makes sense right so this is the
point of Taylor expansion you want to
export approximate original function
and also you want that it suffices to
optimize
zero
because you know if in this beta0
there's no good
um maybe let me let me draw this again
so
so basically what we are saying is there
is a neighborhood
it's got b instead of zero
and this neighborhood first of all you
have say suppose your empirical loss is
looking like this
maybe something else happening somewhere
here I also we don't know so first of
all you if you do the quadratic
approximation
is natural expansion 1 Theta zero
let's say this is Theta zero
you do a quadratic expansion it's
something it looks something like this
it's a very close
because my drawing
so basically you can think this right
one
this right one is G Theta of X and the
black one is f Theta of x
so the quadratic expansion is very close
to the original expansion
sorry the original function and second
you wanted it's the fastest to optimize
here right because if they are if both
the right and and our the black curve
even though they are closed if they are
both you know very high
it doesn't make sense to zoom into this
region right you should leave this
region but you can say that it suffices
to optimize here in terms of the
in the following sense so there exists
an approximate
on global mean
Taylor heart
in b0
sorry I'm using the superscript for zero
for the zero which might be a good
mistake but
let me consistently use that
um
that
I think for in some other lectures I use
superscript for time so that's why I
keep using superscript for time
um anyway so you want to have a say
ahead such that it's Global mean and
actually here you want that L hat
G Theta hat to be approximately zero and
this indicates that you are Global mean
because zero is
is the minimum there is no way you can
go below zero you know so so if you are
close to zero it means you have to be
close to Global here and and this also
implies that
I'll had F Theta
hat is close to zero
okay so but with these two we still
don't really understand what how do how
do we optimize the black curve right so
so you also want to know that optimizing
this loss L hat F Theta
is similar
to optimizing
L hat G Theta
foreign
and not only this but also
and does not
leave
be zero right because if you leave beta0
then all better off right your Taylor
expansion breaks so so you have to say
that when optimized either the L hat F
or the L has G I don't leave this region
so that's so everything is confined to
this region
and
so so this is how we make it work of
course you can ask you know whether this
is really reflecting the
um what happens in reality you know the
answer is no not always but but so far
we are just trying to make this work uh
under certain cases
um
so and so that we can appreciate why
this you know we have to improve this
right so and in some sense three is kind
of like a little bit like extension
so three to some extent is
an
is a follows from one two because if you
are you have a global minimum in this
region right so and and black and white
are closed then why optimizing you know
optimizing I should probably should
converge like that that Global minimum
and you should stay in that region right
to some extent it follows
follows one two
but not exactly you know technically so
so but still requires a formal proof
so what I'm saying is that you know if
you really just want something somewhat
informal to think about the dependency
then probably you only have to first
make sure one two is happening
um and but if you really want
um everything that you you need to um
get approve the three
um
and and you and one two three you can
make this work you know can be out to
in various settings right so with either
over parametrization
or
and or
some particular
particular scaling
of the initialization
so if you play with this transition or
you play with the
um the the width
um and and also you need and small
cluster capacity
um even small or even zero
stochastically
so if you play with the over
parenthesization and scaling of the
initialization and also you insist that
there's no stochasticity that make you
live by go very far
because the sarcastic will make like to
leave the local neighborhood so so
that's why you want small stochasticity
and and how so then you can achieve all
of this and how do you guys most
sarcastically in a nutshell you either
need
by so to guess those small stochasticity
you need to either do smaller enrich
or full batch couldn't be said
so so in sometimes this is the
limitation right so this is the
limitation because you require this and
this is also limitation because you have
to play with it you cannot just to say
and and what you really eventually get
is probably not exactly matching uh what
people do in practice
um
okay
who so
now let's see how do we do uh one two
rest but still like
regardless of all the limitations still
this is kind of interesting or
interesting approach like it's kind of
surprising that such a region even
exists even you think about the one and
two right so you don't care about any
limitations about it it's still kind of
interesting that there exists a such
region that you can basically be close
to a convex function actual quadratic
function if the loss is quadratic right
and and they're still a global minimum
they suggest that there's a lot of
flexibilities
and in this landscape your life works
right so you we have a lot of over
factorizations
um and non-convex students somewhere you
have to have a complex region
right so that's basically we're saying
right so in this landscape globally you
know it's very non-convex very
complicated but there's some special
places in some neighborhoods you are you
are really having a combat function and
that convex function has a global
minimum reaching average zero
so even this is still some surprise
so okay so now let's try to formalize
one two
um and then we talk about three so
how do we do this so let's introduce
some notation like fee
I
to be the Phi of x i the features for
the is example which is religious
and let's define this
feature Matrix
to be
fee and transpose
you put all the features in a row
and this is n by P where p is the number
of parameters
okay so now we can see that
the loss functions with respect to the
linear model
is just a linear regression problem
which you are probably familiar with I'm
taking quadratic loss
or mean Square loss
so
this is just the y i minus Delta Theta
transpose
times Phi of x i
recall that you know you have a
basically linear model in Delta Theta
and square
right so
um I guess maybe it's easier to write in
the other way so that
it's more consistent with the notation
here
transpose Delta State
so if you write in The Matrix notation
this will be 1 over n times
the true Norm of Y minus
Phi times Delta Theta so naught Square
where y y is
the concatenation of all the labels
is in RN
right so this just sounds very familiar
with
linear regression it's just exactly new
regression where Delta Theta is your
parameter V is your design Matrix so all
the other feature Matrix
so and let's assume
this is just for convenience y i is on
the order of one
so that's the two Norms Y is on out of
score
so here is a Lemma that kind of
characterize
what is the uh of
I guess
so it's a Lemma
this is in somewhat for two
and sometimes you are trying to see that
in what neighborhood you have a global
minimum
so so suppose
p is bigger than n you have more
features than the number of data points
and the rank
of this feature Matrix
is equals to n and
the minimum
singular value is equals to Sigma
larger than zero
then
light
be
Norm
Solutions
to y height
to this
all right so you want to fit feedback to
right back and and you you want to
understand you know what is the nearest
Global minimum right so so the other
thing is this is the nearest Global
minimum
so this is in the nearest
Global mean
in some sense right because you know if
you fit it you know you you are
achieving a glow mean and you want the
other side to be the smallest so that
means you are looking for the nearest
one
and if you're looking for the nearest
abundance
you can have a bond on the nearest
Global minimum
where the bound is something like this
square root and over Sigma
so the bond itself so far is not that
you know interpretable but but the point
here is that if you take the ball
this means that if you take the ball
b instead of zero to have this radius
right to to be all the
Theta such that is equals Theta zero
plus Delta Theta
such that
Delta Theta 2 Norm is less than
of square root and sigma over Sigma
then this ball this B Theta will contain
a global mineral
contains
a global mean
okay so so this is characterizing you
know how large the boundary is to be or
how large the region needs to be so you
can contain a global mean
and a number here so far the number is
not interpretable I'm going to compare
it with some other things because
you know by itself you know how large
the region if you just carry about two
then you you can just take the region to
be as large as possible you have to
compare it with something else
and the proof is also pretty easy this
is really just
a simple trivia thing like you say you
can write this outside the hat to be
because you are the so the minimum Norm
solution is the pseudo inverse
of Phi Times by back
and there are some I guess this is not
extremely obvious but you can you know
invoke this is some relatively basic
properties of the pseudo inverse you
know that the operator Norm of the
pseudo inverse is less than
the minimum
singular value of B
actually these are I think are exactly
the same
so and this is equals to 1 over Sigma
and then you you know that you have a
bound on
Delta Theta 2 Norm by
using the operating Norm of the pseudo
inverse of V
times the two Norm of Pi back
so this becomes more over Sigma Times
Square Root
that's it I guess I don't even need a
big O I don't know why I have to be go
sorry
just for me like it's always safe to
have big also so it's just a part of my
brain
it cannot work we speak without people
anyway but here you'll need anything and
a constant
so oh I guess oh I guess there's a I
think I need a big O because I'm only
assuming that why it's on on the order
of square rooting
sorry so because here I'm only assuming
this is
why it's less than o square rooted so
that's why
I need to be go
but anyway the constant doesn't matter
here
um you get the point I guess
so Okay so
any questions so far
so and now let's see whether this region
is whether it's too big or too small
right it sounds somewhat big because
only is there right but actually you'll
see that the region is not that big
because the sigma could be made very big
in some sense
um all all there are some relative kind
of things which you have to compare it
with something else right so because you
have to compare this with how good you
have approximation in the region so next
one is for suleima
so this is for one
in some sense so suppose
this
is beta ellipsis
suppose this gradient of
the the network is ellipses in Theta
in a sense that
for every X for every Theta and Theta
Prime you have this
so I think this is zero
because we always only care about the
green I'd say that zero evaluate let's
say that zero
wait sorry my bad this is you viewed it
sorry my back okay so this is a so here
what I'm writing here this is a function
of theta because I evaluate at some some
arbitrary state that I see
so I want this as a function of failure
to be ellipsis in Theta so that means
that if you choose two different
place where either Theta or Theta Prime
the differences between them in L2 Norm
I have to use L2 Norm here because there
are vectors and you want to say that L2
Norm is bounded by
the the differences in the the failure
space
so if you have this then
we know that
after the x minus G Theta X
your approximation is less than
Big O O beta times the difference
on
the Delta Theta through Norm square
right because the difference between
these two is basically in some sense
depends on how far you are away from the
reference point right if at the
reference point it should be exactly the
same
and if you're a little bit more away
from the reference point then you're
going to incur some logs and the loss is
something on the second order right
that's that's also intuitive
so and the important thing is that so
for every Theta in the B set at zero
that we just have to we just defined
we have that F Theta
x minus G Theta X
is less than beta n Square over Sigma
Square
and that's just by plugging in the
definition of beta0 the b0 has this
radius
squared n over Sigma and you plug it in
into this here
then you get uh so you plug in this here
you got that in this video you have some
bound on how good your approximation is
so
oh sorry this
let's try this video
copy pasting error okay
unscore
okay so far this bounce
so I saw a question
um by the way you can feel free to
unmute but I can read the question right
now so
how does how do we define fee
superscript plus oh this is the
so what is this free plus this is the
pseudo inverse
of B
uh I think this is called uh
there's actually this is the most common
definition of pseudo Universal fee
um I guess you can
roughly think of as the V inverse of V
um with some small caveat
uh
yeah yes more Tangos to the inverse
thanks for the comments in the chat
um
um this is I think this is supposed to
be taught in the linear algebra course
maybe I don't know like um I'm not sure
whether what I can say about it what you
know about it is that
at least in this case
uh
I think maybe just so that's for the
sake of Simplicity just to think of the
pseudo universe as the inverse so if you
are not super familiar with it
um and and then you can verify this is a
good solution uh to this equation right
because if you multiply so the inverse
you get you get this to the inverse
cancels with Phi and you get Delta Theta
so so sorry so so you guys so you plug
in this data to this equation you can
cancel Phi and V to the inverse and you
get y back
um that's how you get the
um how do you verify this is a solution
to the equation
Okay so
um and and also another I think another
useful thing to know is that the pseudo
inverse has exactly the same it has the
inverse of the spectrum of the original
one right so suppose the fee has
singular value
Sigma 1 up to Sigma k
and then fee pseudo inverse
has
singular value
one over Sigma 1 up to one over Sigma k
so
um and this you know if all these sigmas
are positive right you ignore the zero
singular values then this is exactly
true so the singular value such as the
code inverted
um
Okay cool so
I hope that answers the question
um okay going back to the second lever
for number one so this is saying that
you know in this neighborhood how good
your approximation is right so we got
this you know like uh uh number so I'm
going to explain this number uh that's
the important thing right so how small
is this right if this is small that's
great if this is big that's a problem so
but maybe just let me just say the proof
for this Lemma the proof of the Lima is
kind of like basically this follows the
basic fact that
from the fact that
um if you have H
Theta satisfies
gradient of hclipses
and this green inflation is basically
equivalent to the hyphen
he offered a norm is followed by Beta
and if if everything is differentiable
then you know you can bounce the quality
of the Taylor expansion
so you can say that she is Theta minus G
to the h0
minus gradient H 0
this is bounded by
o of data
Theta minus 0 to 2 square
Phenom square and this H Theta will be
just F Theta X
in our case if we take a Theta to be F
the X then you get
um
you get the Dilemma above
so so the point is that you you the
approximation error is
second order in the the outside in the
difference between your point and the
reference point
so
okay and there's a small remark another
small remark is that
um if if the F Theta involves value
then
uh number of data is not even continuous
so you cannot it cannot be ellipse
everywhere
and this requires some special fix so
requires
special
fixes the fixes is not that you know
surprising uh just because even though
it's not continuous everywhere it still
continues almost everywhere so so
basically it's kind of close to
reluctious and in some sense IO F Theta
X is is still like if you look at the
average over data points then you still
have some relapiousness but I think
let's let's now discuss that it's a
little bit kind of like a low level
details which is not important we can
just assume we are dealing with a
um not well we are dealing with
something like sigmoid then then there
is no such issue
Okay cool so now let's go back to the
the main thing right so the main thing
is that whether this is a good balance
right so like you say that you have
found this three the zero
and you have shown that in this video
you have such a good approximate you
have such an approximation error so
important fact is that what is this beta
and the sigma Square it's this small or
bad
and the important thing is that
so the the interesting thing is that
this thing is not scaling environment so
only is something you cannot change
right but B over bait over 6 is not
scaling environment
so what does that mean that's I think
you can interpret this in some way so
but but in some sense like beta
basically I think the the easiest way to
think about is that you have a square in
below right you have beta the the the
the beta on top so so somehow you can
play with the scaling so to make this
going to zero
so there are two cases
actually there are more than two cases
but I'm going to discuss two cases these
are in different papers but I'm going to
unify them in the following way so there
are two cases where
beta over Sigma Square can go to zero
so the first way is that you can replay
my choice
uh with a scalar
and this is uh inches Act
I think this is 19 and the paper is
called lazy tuning
often it might work something like that
so I guess the paper title suggests that
they're saying that this is a lazy way
of changing networks it's not really the
final way you should believe it
um but nevertheless the paper is very
nice so and what they do is the
following so they say that
um the large
so let your F the X your
parametricization
to be the following you take the alpha
times let's say I've say the bar X
so and this let's make this a fixed this
is actually this is a standard right for
a standard
there are not
uh and fixed
fixed in the sense that you don't change
the architecture right you don't like
the you just take whatever standing
right track you know with any Finance
with
um which fix your fixed with
um
and and depth so and so forth right
something that you don't change at least
for this perspective and you only change
Alpha right so forever Alpha you define
perfect it's a very nice workplace just
you have a different scaling in front of
it right so so Alpha you got the right
work and then let's see how does
everything change as you change Alpha
and also you fix initialization takes
initialization
scheme 0
and then let's consider uh let's say
setup bar Sigma bar is the sigma mean
of the of the of the base Network let's
say the base network is the F Bar so
right so it's the second mean of this
base one
right this is the
right on the beta bar with the
ellipselessness beta bar be
deliciousness
also of the base one
so you can think of Sigma bar and beta
bar are not changing us
as you change Alpha right so and now
let's see how does the alpha change the
final segment beta of your final Network
right so then
so Sigma is equal to Alpha Sigma bar
because once you have considered F Theta
you multiply as Alpha right so all the
features right like the gradient becomes
Alpha times bigger and then everything
becomes Alpha times bigger
right so
um right this is just because when you
take the gradient with respect to
so this is just because of chain rule
right so if you take root in respect to
Theta of the f is the same as Alpha
times the gradient of theta with back to
uh uh like the the gradient of f bar
with back to Theta right so you have a
channel
so everything got scaled and beta also
got scaled by Alpha just because you
know the gradient got scaled for the
same reason
and then you can see that you get for
free of some Factor about Alpha and this
equation so beta over Sigma squared
becomes
beta bar over Sigma bar squared times 1
over Alpha
and this can go to zero as Alpha goes to
Infinity
so basically they're saying that you
know whatever Network you take whatever
initialization right so as long as you
your Sigma bar is better bar they are
reasonable and they are not
zero or something like that right so so
um so as long as Sigma bar is not zero
so so you have some beta bar over Sigma
bar square that might be bad but you can
always rescale re-parametrate it with a
constant in front of it
so that this key quantity Beta Sigma
Square becomes going to zero and if this
goes to zero what does it mean it means
that your approximation becomes better
better right so and they till some point
if if you change your Alpha large enough
you make this approximation super good
right so and in the neighborhood so
basically you found the neighborhood
such that in that neighborhood your
approximation is very good if you take
Alpha to be big
no the last one wouldn't change right
because the laws that's a good question
it allows what is the loss loss is
something composed with the
uh composed on top of with the with the
network right so the loss is
out of for example
Alpha F Bar
Theta X
y right
so
so first of all an initialization we
always try to make the initialization
zero zero the the output adding
transition zero so that wouldn't change
and second
even though a p
seemingly this whole thing is Big sure
that's true but we show that you have a
global minimum
where this be in this neighborhood you
have a global minimum
I'm not sure whether it makes sense so
so in some sense I think okay let me try
to draw a figure to answer this question
so the question is that you know what
happens when Alpha is Big it sounds like
function value becomes big right
so
that's true but I think you see you
I think what happens is that for example
suppose you have
um
not sure so
how do I visualize this so use
I think your loss will be so if you
stretch Alpha your loss will be sharper
your loss so if you look at everything
you look at a dependency on Alpha right
so if you make alpha bigger
you make this neighborhood smaller
right
so you make the neighborhood smaller so
you're gonna get something like like
this very sharp in the neighborhood
and uh however
so so so so if Alpha is bigger actually
you can find even something that is very
close by
uh to make the so like you even you have
to even leave move even
less
from neutralization
that's because if you do a little bit of
work then you actually already kind of
like
uh already fixed the data
I'm not sure why did that make sense so
okay so so there's always okay so
there's always one thing which is useful
which is like the F set of zero X this
is zero
so basically like you always start with
this
right where you don't have any scale
right so this is just literally zero and
if Alpha is Big then this is still zero
right
but when Alpha is Big you are more
sensitive to Theta
right so that's why if you change a
little bit
then you can already fit your data
so you only have to change very very
little
from the cellular zero to straighter
data
and and and and when you change very
little then you actually your
approximation is very good in that
neighborhood
I'm not sure whether that makes some
sense
but maybe you can discuss you know it's
a little bit counterintuitive I agree
but right it's just it really because
the only thing that happens here is that
how does this beta and sigma reality the
the relative difference between beta and
sigma how does that depend on Alpha
right so
um
so
so in some sense the if you have larger
Alpha you need to have smaller
neighborhoods but but but but your um
but but the approximation hours scales
you know faster
because because your function is kind of
much much kind of like more
non-smooth right so like your function
becomes like sharper so but but actually
the neighborhood shrinks faster than the
the the the sharpness
growth so that's why it's working
yeah
I hope that somewhat answers the
question right
um yeah but this is generally this is
kind of somewhat kind of confusing
um and this is another case where we can
also see this
so
um the other case is if you over Prime
my twice
so
and
so here let's say suppose this is a this
is actually the original
um or the original uh first few papers
uh that you know like which invents the
the ntk approach take so um
so basically what you do is you say you
have a model
uh wire hat which is equals to Y squared
and times sum of a i Sigma W I transpose
X this is a two layer Network
with M neurons and I'm scaling this
so in some sense mostly for convenience
uh because you know whatever skill you
do you can also change other skills to
compensate
um and and the convenience comes from
that you know if I choose the
everything on order of one then this
will output something on all of one
which we'll see so but maybe let's
discuss that in a moment after I
introduce the notation so I'm gonna have
this Matrix w
which contains all the rows
and W is in
I'm by D
and and sigma is value here
um I guess let's say is maybe let's not
say Sigma zero Sigma is
something like uh
it's one ellipsis
and it has second another derivative
second now the derivative
so actually
yeah so
you wouldn't see how those coming into
play especially they're not super
important and what is the neutralization
does AI zero
so actually AI
is initialized to be
plus one minus one
uh initially
and not optimized at all
so they are not even parameters
technically speaking
and WIS are parameters w i zero is
initialized from gaussian
a d dimensional gaussian with safer
cocoa virus
and let's say x has the norm the norm of
X is on out of one
is on out of one
um this is just for convenience so that
we have a fixed scaling
and unless it's
let's let's say Theta to the the
parameter Theta is really just the
a vector version
D times m is just real Vector rise to
version of w so vectorized
version
of
w
Okay so
and
so we'll assume
I'm close to Infinity
like uh so so I'm is eventually
technically poorly
and then D so A and D are considered to
be fixed and I mean something that will
becomes bigger and bigger and and and
that's the power so like everything
comes from the the scaling of M
so I guess just to explain why we all
want to have this smaller squared I'm an
initialization scale like this
so
scaling and I think the reason at least
one reason is that
if you take if you look at this so Sigma
w i zero transpose X this is on order of
one
because wi is a spherical gaussian and X
has no one a spherical gaussian times a
number one thing will have expectation
like will roughly be on all of one and
it will take some value or kind of
something like relative more than you
are Beyond you're going to be on out of
one and then uh the sum of this
will be on the order of square root n
right because you have I'm of these
things that are somewhat plus one minus
one and
um and you because AI is plus one minus
one so you cancel them in some sense and
then you get
so and that means I've Theta 0x is on
out of one
because um you'd have another a one over
script I'm in front
so that's why
that's one of the reason why you choose
this game
okay uh and okay so so initially our
output is on the out of one
and now let's see how does the segment
beta depends on all of these qualities
um so we hope that this this key
quantity beta over Sigma Square
to go to zero as M goes to Infinity
so um
so let's first look at the sigma Sigma
is the sigma mean
of this
feature Matrix fee
and
and you can this is also the same as
the sigma mean
of
this fee feature transpose
um this is just equality because Fifi
transpose the spectrum is just a squared
of the respectable fee
and what is VP transpose Fifi transpose
is basically this empirical kernel
Matrix right
the IGS actually is just the inner
product
between
two features of two examples
right so and and let's look at what the
scaling of this Fifi transpose so to do
that you have to look at what's the
gradient
so let's look at the gradient
so F Theta if you look at the derivative
of the output
with respect to each of this WI
then you can use chain Rule and and
then you can get something like this
time sucks
so this is the gradient of every neuron
wi every Vector WI
and
that means that if you look at the
gradient the entire gradient
all the the other vectors feel like the
norm then it's more over M times
the sum over m
W I transpose x times x to null
Square which is
1 over n times the two Norm of x squared
times
and and what is this it's kind of hard
to know exactly what is this but I think
you mostly care about what's the
dependency
on app
right so what's the dependency on M then
this as M goes to Infinity by
concentration
by concentration
so if as and goes to Infinity this is
really just converting to expectation
because this is the empirical sum
there's a y over M here right so Sigma
Prime W transpose X
Square where W is from
simple precautions
times the true Norm of x square which is
a constant which is one basically right
so
um and this whole thing will not depend
on
this whole thing will be something like
o of one so I guess you know to see it's
all one maybe it's
some someone tricky but at least you
know that this is not
depending
on
so so m is not in in this equation so so
basically this is saying that
um every
every quantity here
as M goes to Infinity you know it's sum
the norm of this is on all of one
doesn't change that M goes to Infinity
and also you can do the same thing for
uh
the inner product of two
for example
the same thing happens that if you look
at the inner product it's something like
this
I
transpose
so this is
I think they're technically there should
be a zero here
this is the initial addition
Prime
and as M goes to Infinity
so as M goes to Infinity by
concentration this is Con concentrated
around the expectation of it the
expectation is something like Sigma
Prime
w
I transpose X Sigma Prime W I transpose
X the
okay
yes I can write following W transpose X
Sigma Prime W transpose X Prime
times x in the product with X Prime
where W is from
vertical gaussian
right
okay so again this doesn't depend does
not
depend on M
okay so so which means that so basically
this is saying that this entire Matrix
Fifi transpose
you know goes to a some kind of a
constant Matrix
constant Matrix
as M goes to Infinity
and I think this Matrix sometimes people
call it t Infinity
um and and this is the the neural Canon
kernel this is the neural tangent kernel
with m is equals to Infinity
okay so this is the fixed Matrix and you
can show that
uh
and you can show that this is
a matrix that
um that is like a at least High sum is a
Forex
so
I'm gonna skip this part so it can be
shown that
is K Infinity is full rank
so and let's take Sigma mean
to be the sigma mean of K Infinity which
is larger than zero
um
then basically you can show that the fee
fee transpose
for the sigma meal free fee transpose
sorry
this is you know
larger than for example up half times
Sigma mean
if I'm is sufficiently Big just because
you know fee fee transpose is converging
to the the constant Matrix K Infinity so
so if I'm insufficiently big then you
should your eigenvalue should also
converge this part again is not
like I didn't do it exactly uh uh
rigorously but you can expect that when
you converge to some Matrix your
eigenvalue should also your your
spectral your spectrum should also
converts to that Matrix
um
okay so
um so with all of this right so
basically this saying your Sigma
um is not this is our Sigma right the
sigma is not changing in some sense as M
goes to Infinity but let's see what what
beta changes so now
how beta changes
as M goes to Infinity we'll show that
the beta will goes to zero as M goes to
Infinity so that beta over Sigma Square
the key quantity will go to zero
and
um
okay so now what we do is that
um so we want to look at the
ellipselessness
of beta which means that you care about
these two things the difference between
these two things
and we have computed you know what the
the gradient is the gradient in every
this both of these are Matrix matrices
because Theta is a matrix right so and
each uh the gradient of each column of
our h
rho is something like this right so this
is really a matrix with entries
foreign
right so you have each of these
integrated so that's why if you look at
the norm
between these two
if you look at the euclidean norm
then it's the pro is the sum of the
Norms of each of the components
so you got 1 over n which is come from
this small squared and and then you look
at the norm of each of these components
this is a scalar this is a vector so you
get X
two Norm times the scalar Sigma Prime
so x minus Sigma Prime w i Prime
transpose X
squared
right so and then so suppose you you
want to get let's say let's try to get
rid of this Sigma Prime so let's say
this is less than one over m
times
just without the sigma Prime and this is
your similar Sigma Prime is
Sigma Prime is one leptus or five
lectures
because let's pay our Big O here
and then of course this doesn't work for
Value as I said before value we have to
fix it in some in some way
um
okay so and then you say that
this is
you get rid of the ax again so
M times
[Music]
I guess the norm of X is one as we
claimed so and this one we just use
culture schwares let's say w i minus w i
Prime
score two Norm Square
uh times X2 Norm Square
that's this part
and X2 Norm square is also one so we can
just
and then this is one over n times
the distance between Theta and Theta
Prime in your cleaning distance
so
so this is saying that deluxiousness
is one over m
oh I guess delicious needs more squared
and because we didn't take the square
root right so
X
so Norm is less than 1 over square root
of M
so
so beta is one over square root n
and now if we look at this P quantity
beta over Sigma Square then this is
equals to 1 over square root of M over
Sigma Sigma is something like Sigma bar
Square so sorry Sigma is this
something that doesn't depend on M right
so Sigma mean
Square
right so this will go to zero
as M goes to Infinity
so so here I think the the radius you
need is always the same
because Sigma is always the same but
your function becomes more and more
smooth
uh your gradient becomes more ellipses
as you have more and more neurons so so
that's why eventually as you have more
neurons you can get into this regime
uh let me see
oh
my God
so I guess let me take the next 10
minutes to discuss the outline of the
next steps
so so any questions so far
so now suppose let's try to establish
three so we call that 3 is about
optimizing G and optimizing over
f are similar
right so
um
I can you can basically do two things
right so like all the analysis there are
a lot of different ways to analyze this
and all the analysis kind of like take
probably you can think of as two steps
implicitly even though the first step
probably don't have to write in the
paper but I'm pretty sure many people do
that when they derive the on the
analysis so your first step it sounds
reasonable to say that you first
optimize you analyze optimization
of L height
G Theta
and the second step is that you somehow
analyze
optimization of iof Heights F Theta
by
someone reusing
reusing proofs
in a in some way of course you cannot
reuse exactly but you can probably use
most of the ideas right so
and and and your intuition is that these
two things are similar so somehow you
can
reuse the proof to do the the actual
optimization for the new actual F data
right so and there are two ways to do
to for for a
I think essentially you can say two ways
maybe there's possibility that I missed
some of the existing papers but roughly
speaking there are two ways for a and
therefore there are two ways for B in
some sense
so
so the first way let's say I is that you
Leverage
uh the strong convexity
of this L height G Theta
um and then
show
exponential convergence
I have to say that this you know the
definition of strong complexity I'm not
sure whether I have really given it in
this course
um this is a stronger notion of
convexity if you haven't heard of it
um You probably don't you know it's not
super essential for this course but if
you have heard of it you know what kind
of what kind of things I'm talking about
because this the analyzing a this is
analyzing how to optimize a convex
function it does require a little bit of
optimization background uh at least it
took like on a conceptual level you you
can imagine there are many different
ways to analyze all organizations for
um regression so so strong complexity is
the stronger version of convexity and
you can somewhat use that to get the
very fast convergence rate exponential
means every time you Decay the error by
a constant Factor so that you get
exponential decay of the errors and
another way to do this is that you don't
use the strong convex teeth
because sometimes you actually don't
have the strong complexity in certain
cases so you don't use the strong
complexity but only use the smoothness
the smoothness means that you have a
bonding technology derivative
um and again if you have taken some
courses about optimization then this
would make a lot of sense probably
because there are different ways to
analyze optimization sometimes you only
have smoothness you have a different
kind of analysis
um
so
um and based on these two approaches you
know you can get two different proofs
for b as well and we're only going to
talk about a
so we only talk about a
sometimes I talk about
I the first approach
um and and for this approach there is no
no prior knowledge is required you
probably wouldn't understand exactly
what I'm saying about this conceptual
thing but the actual proof doesn't
require
prior knowledge and it's actually also
pretty intuitive by itself as well
so um I think we're going to talk about
the approach um the concrete analysis uh
next week next lecture but I mean before
ending this lecture let me make another
remark which I think is useful
and in some sense it's useful
for two for the second approach more but
it's also useful for the first approach
so this is a interesting
observation
or maybe intuition you can say
so
um and particularly useful for two
so so this is
at any
Theta t
suppose you take this Taylor expansion
take Taylor expansion
uh with reference point
Theta T so now we are not taking the
expansion instead of zero which I can
tell expansion until a t you can Define
this g t Theta X is a function of theta
t
and I have
gradient of theta t
x times Theta minus Theta t
so this is the linear function
um
and then you can consider
um
l f Theta
at Theta T right so this is the gradient
that you actually you are
this is the
gradient
I
you are taking
because you are you would really care
about optimizing app right so this is
what you are taking but actually it's
the same
as the gradient
of this
title expansion
at the same point
so these two things
yes there's two t here this is Theta T
and this T is indicating that this is
also Taylor expression at the reference
functionality
so so why this is the case you know I
guess you know if you want you can take
the derivative and you can verify it but
but fundamentally this is actually
it's really just saying that I have said
that he
after and
GS agree
up to
first order
T this is material expansion if they
agree after first order I said t and
then
anything that
like I'll so so this implies
IO of f Theta and
L of G Theta t
also Gray
up to first order
all right CLT
so
so so that's why
um
so so what does this really mean this
really means that gradient descent
on F on this function on or maybe on
technical
IO had F Theta
right you are taking ingredients only
with respect to the the f
this is the same
as taking
online green descent
on
I guess I haven't defined online when
you said but let me Define that in a
moment after write down our sequence
of changing objective
LG Theta
0 up to I'll
G30
so what does our language in design
really mean it just really means that
you every time you take the gradient of
the new function you have a sequence of
functions and every time you take you
get a new function and you take the
gradient of that function you take one
step
so that's online reading results so
so basically you are saying that hey I'm
going inside on this fixed function L
hat is the same as taking
gradients updates with this with respect
to a sequence of changing functions
and this is actually how the Second Step
the second approach really worked so so
this means that you can
use
online
uh learning approach
I guess
in this in this in this culture I'm not
planning to talk about online learning
but online learning is trying to deal
with
the case where you have a changing
sequence of changing functions right so
you are not optimizing a single function
you have a changing for example changing
distribution or changing environment or
changing loss function whatsoever so so
there's a rich literature on how do you
analyze optimization when you have a
sequence of changing loss functions and
this is exactly how
um uh what this is about right you are
having a sequence of change in loss
functions and
um and E and if you can analyze that you
can analyze the original cases
now here they're also like special
structures about these loss functions
because they're all somewhere similar to
each other right so they are all kind of
expansions
um with respects to reference points
that are in a small region so you can
also leverage additional information
about that
so yeah so this is chapter 10 in the
lecture notes but I think in this
quarter I just don't think we have time
to uh go there
um okay I think I'm already five minutes
late
um and next lecture we are going to talk
about the the the the approach one which
is more self-content and
um and uh also kind of cleaner to some
extent
um okay maybe just the last comment I
think there are many different
um neurotangent criminal papers
um
I I'm I probably I'm not super
comprehensive but I think most of them
basically is a combination of
these several things right so one thing
is that you have to optimize this
establish this third step of
optimization and you have two ways two
large ways and maybe some even subtle
differences under underlying differences
and also you have to establish the
the first two properties and those are
properties about not about optimization
they're about your parametrization of
your function plus your initialization
right so there you can also have a bunch
of different flexibilities you can
change the reference the the scaling you
can change the the wealth you can do
many different things or you can even
change for example the uh the
architecture uh in certain cases to make
it you know more
um more efficient or less efficient in
certain cases
um so
um
yeah so so so I'm not I don't want to
have a very comprehensive discussion of
this ntk just because there are so many
limitations but I think it's a useful
thing to know given that there are so
many Works in that and and there there
are indeed some nice ideas there
um
Okay cool so I guess I'll continue uh
next Wednesday next